hi guys I'm Deidre Behar and I'm Katy
Kraus and we're here in defense of
Britney Spears all right let's not
sugarcoat this at all it hasn't been an
easy ride for Brit Brit she went through
a divorce she went to a psychiatric hold
the umbrella the shaving of the head all
that stuff happened and she emerged she
overcame all the obstacles in her life
and she's better than ever today can we
talk about how not only is she one of
the most famous people in the world but
she's also the classiest celebrity to
ever walk the face of this earth she has
had so many moments where other
celebrities diss her Justin Timberlake
I'm looking at you Brittany has always
said and I'm quoting good morals I mean
waiting to have sex until after you've
been married did you and she live up to
this during your relationship sure she's
never once in an interview on her
Twitter on her Instagram on her facebook
said a bad word about any other
celebrity because that is how a classy
southern queen would behave undeniably
Britney Spears is a phenomenal mother
okay she makes co-parenting with Kevin
Federline works so nicely and she spends
all her free time at soccer games and
going on hikes and going on vacations
with her boys Sean Preston and Jaden
James she's a pop star she can do
anything with her free time the fact
that she chooses to spend it with her
family warms my heart where a Spears is
34 years old she's never looked better
of her entire life to make me video
rolling around in the bed with that guy
goatee gold and then you see her on her
Instagram and she's posting about like
her fitness her body
hashtag body goals Katie and I have
waited nine long insanely long years to
get Britney Spears back on the VMA stage
and finally it is happening we don't
talk about that little moment in 2007 we
know this weekend she is going to bring
it there's gonna be energy and
feistiness and costumes and glitter I'm
ready you know what I feel like she is
the ultimate VMA Queen yes and of course
we have to talk about the new album
glory I know right off the bat there was
a lot of criticism a lot of critiques I
was going through the YouTube comments
on the make me video some fans less than
impressed but you guys this is
Britney Spears we are talking about
let's give her the benefit of the doubt
yet this album is going to be amazing
I've already heard a couple of the songs
it is outrageous that's a pun for you
the fact that she's even still making
music goes to say so much so many of her
colleagues that I think of don't Bank
music anymore yes and she is like thank
you God nee it's pretty big
let's end this tribute to Brittany by
talking about our favorite moment in
Brittany history what is yours so I feel
like it's one of the most iconic photos
ever it's when her and Justin Timberlake
wore those damn Dynamo matching outfits
and I'm sorry she is a staple on the red
carpets I returned hot seat I mean I
think you know what I'm gonna go with
this snake nobody was more fearless than
Britney I'm sorry you'd have to pay me a
lot of money to get me on a stage with a
Python dangling around my neck not only
did she walk with a Python around her
neck she did full-blown choreography
with a Python around her neck and that
is something that not anybody can do
only God nee Britney Spears can do thank
you honorable mention every time she
hits the stage and dances oh my god
every time all right guys we want to
keep the Britney combo going so let us
know what your absolute favorite Britney
moment is in the comment section below
yes and let's keep the conversation
going on Twitter as well at Katy
underscore Kraus at her name is Deidre
and please subscribe to entertainment
tonight's YouTube channel for all things
Britney and so so so much more we'll see
you next time bye